hey 42 here keeping yourself alive is
hard work
there were bacteria covered children
ready to give you numerous diseases
there's delicious junk food that will
swell your heart up and make it stop
working and there are evil monsters
hiding under your bed waiting to eat
your face sorry kids but it's true most
of the time though we rely on doctors to
make sure we don't accidentally trip and
fall face-first into an early grave they
help us to make the decisions about how
best to keep all the nasty stuff at bay
not that we always take the advice that
is because you know there's stuff like
donuts and cheesecake in the world but
there are situations when a doctor can
say actually you know what I'm afraid
your time is up when times are tough for
everything has just gone wrong how much
say does a doctor have and whether you
should continue to live or not can a
doctor legally kill their patients in
most parts of the modern world
if you rushed into an emergency room
with blood spraying all over the place
of a limb dangling off you'd expect the
nearest doctor to tell mrs. Johnson
that's her bowel movement diary we'll
have to wait till next Monday and run
over to help you but throughout history
especially whilst at war the doctors
couldn't possibly attend all the
patients that they had so they would
have to choose who to help for a long
time this would have been done at random
doctors picking the people nearest to
them or simply the ones who smelts the
most pleasant but as medicine became
increasingly more scientific doctors
realized that who they helped and in
what order could have a big impact on
the long-term survival rates of troops
during the Napoleonic Wars and World War
one French doctors began using a system
called triage where they would arrange
ly injured into three sections
those likely to live without treatment
those likely to die even with treatment
and those for whom immediate care might
make a big difference in their chances
so if you've been shot in the arm then
you just
to sit and wait if you've been shot in
the chest then please just die quietly
in the corner but you with the bleeding
kidney get over here so we can sew you
up and shut up boy you're noisy
complaining this basic model is still
what a paramedic might do today if they
were dealing with 50 people all on their
own but there is a surprising lack of
consensus on what to do in a major
emergency and often even hospitals do
not have a concrete policy for triage in
the aftermath of Hurricane Katrina many
hospitals were cut off without power and
had to make very difficult choices as to
flood water and temperature rose and
their supplies dwindled a Memorial
Medical Center New Orleans a doctor and
two nurses made the difficult decision
to give lethal drug doses to some
patients who are in a great deal of pain
and had virtually no chances of survival
the case against them for second-degree
murder was eventually thrown out by the
Louisiana courts so to answer the
question yes in this instance at least a
doctor was able to legally kill patients
but it's wider impact was a realization
that doctors needed a more concrete
framework to work within these horrible
situations
dr. Doherty bittitan decided that these
life-and-death questions should have the
input of the general public and led a
series of forums to see what everyday
people fought there was general
agreement that you should prioritize the
people with the best chances of living
longer but once that has been set how do
you choose within those groups of equal
chance survivors the do you pick parents
over single people what happens to
illegal immigrants can you discriminate
by age and if they are a believer does
that put them at the bottom of every
list these emergency extremes are
fortunately quite rare and hospitals
have often dealt incredibly well with a
sudden influx of patients the general
public have reacted amazingly well to in
the aftermath of the Boston Marathon
bombings sub competitors who had just
run a marathon kept running to the
hospital in order to give blood I bet
you feel pretty
easy right now but these life-and-death
choices come up every day in hospitals
since we now have an amazing ability to
keep people alive when their body is
really letting the side down whatever
organ malfunctions there are machines to
do its work from kidney dialysis to
artificial heart and iron lungs even
when someone is completely brain dead
meaning they have no electrical activity
in their brain we can keep the body
going for about a week
in 2005 the UK introduced the Mental
Capacity Act which laid out guidelines
for who gets to make decisions about a
patient's future it states that you have
the capacity to make your own medical
choices even if they mean certain death
it backs this up by stating that you
can't be deemed incapable of making
decisions just because you make an
unwise choice it's like how your friends
still listen to you even though you once
said the Wolverine was the best film
ever made
what if you are incapable of making that
decision then the choice you averts to
the doctor unless you have already
selected a person to speak for you such
as a parent a friend or if you don't
have any friends then maybe nominate a
fortune cookie you found on the shelf so
you are allowed to refuse care even if
it's necessary to keep you alive but
what about the opposite what about when
you're in a hurry to check out and you
want the doctor to be a little generous
on the MOR fee euthanasia was looked
down upon for hundreds of years
especially among the judeo-christian
religions who claimed it went against
the sanctity of human life in the same
way that people who commit suicide were
not allowed to be buried in official
cemeteries but in 1870 a British
schoolteacher called Samuel Williams
gave a speech in Birmingham about giving
chloroform to terminally ill patients
the transcript was published widely and
it sparked an important debate in the US
the first attempt to legalize euthanasia
came in 1906 in Ohio when a wealthy
woman called Anna Hall started a
campaign after watching her mother fight
a long and hopeless battle with liver
cancer
of course this isn't just a decision for
doctors it's something the military have
faced for a long long time a coup de
Gras or mercy killing has happened for
centuries when soldiers take pity on an
enemy who is in great pain
SAS soldier sergeant Colin McLaughlin is
currently under investigation for a
claim that he did this in Iraq mercy
killings violate the Geneva Convention
which are the rules of combat asked for
the medical side of things though right
now euthanasia is legal in the
Netherlands Belgium Colombia and
Luxembourg there is also the case of
assisted suicide where the patient's
themselves are the one to administer the
treatment usually some kind of drug this
is legal in four countries and some US
states but your best bet to avoid all of
this scary life-and-death stuff is to
just live a good healthy life and the
next time your doctor advises you to
stop drinking so much and do more
exercise you should probably listen
because remember if he is smart enough
he can probably kill you and get away
with it thanks for the view subscribe
for more 40 - a man known simply as
Ziona has a grand total of 39 wives and
he is the head of the world's largest
family welcome - what what the most
densely populated place on earth kowloon
walled city was home to over 33,000
people